la victoire des deux fernandez et
éclatantes et dès son élection la future
vice présidente a demandé au président
sortant mauricio macri de mettre de
l'ordre dans les finances publiques
d'ici décembre et palau favor la
première mesure c'est la banque centrale
qui l'a prise pour freiner la fuite des
capitaux défense de changer pour plus de
200 dollars américains par mois
le dollar est une valeur refuge ici déjà
des épargnants argentins ont retiré en
deux mois 12 milliards de dollars dans
la perspective d'une élection d
fernandez
ce matin le dollar officielle est resté
stable mais il a monté au marché noir ce
qu'on appelle le dollar blue les marchés
voient d'un mauvais oeil le retour des
politiques populistes des douze ans des
gouvernements kirchner de 2003 2004 un
gouvernement marqué aussi par les
affaires de corruption
cristina kirchner fait face à 11
poursuites devant les tribunaux
le journaliste de la nacion diego
qu'abbott a révélé l'existence de huit
cahiers d'écoliers dans lesquelles un
chauffeur de taxi a documenté
précisément pendant dix ans c'est
convoyage de pots-de-vin de grandes
entreprises vers les résidences de
nestor et de cristina kirchner et total
100 millions de dollars des dizaines de
témoins et d'accuser encore au bord et
toutes les transactions mais on
soupçonne que les fonds détournés par
les kirchner sont beaucoup plus
importants on parle de 38 milliards de
dollars soit le montant du dernier prêt
du fmi à l'argentine tout le monde l'a
chargé christine a aussi a changé
homme de gauche le célèbre cinéaste pino
solanas était l'adversaire de cristina
kirchner
il a changé de camp il vient d'être élu
député
je n'ai rybacki navx qui n'avoue pas
mais il dit que la corruption du
gouvernement macri était pire l'état est
était un territoire de chasse pour faire
des affaires personnelles avec eux que
faites vous des cas de corruption des
questionnaires cissé nord nombreuses
inopérables incomparable
les gens sont habitués au manque
d'infrastructures d'institutions ou de
justice alors la corruption pour eux
pour la société c'est quelque chose de
normal maillot c'est thomas commandant
social de mangue maillot normal diego
qu'abbott crois que les poursuites
n'iront nulle part en tant que vice
présidente cristina kirchner retrouvera
l'immunité dont elle jouissait comme
sénatrice
si jamais elle était condamnée pour la
destituer il faudrait un vote des deux
tiers de la chambre des députés et du
sénat dont elle sera la présidente et
jean michel leprince pas du canada rue à
lodève